donc grenier entrant par
une équipe multi
la maison d'alexander et de lioudmila
n'est pas si loin une quinzaine de
kilomètres à peine mais s'y rendre
représente aujourd'hui un long périple
parsemé d'embûches des points de
contrôle
et des carcasses de blindés calcinés
autant de vestiges des violents combats
qui se sont déroulés ici
le village de villecroze cas est en
bonne partie détruit
mais au calme relatif est revenu depuis
qu'ils soient des russes se sont retirés
alors oleksandr élus ni la en profite
pour revenir voir leur maison
aussitôt accueilli par reed gic le chien
des voisins qu'ils croyaient mort un
soulagement
mais leur maison elle est en piètre état
alors ce qui me rend toi qui vois là dit
il à quoi ressemble la paix russes
un obus tombés dans le jardin a ravagé
la façade les dommages sont importants
facteurs france cauchemar cauchemar
c'est un cauchemar un cauchemar c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait est horrible mona soyez
emilie est à charge c'est notre terre
notre mère patrie précise-t-il et
personne ne va nous forcer à partir
d'ici moi s'il n'est ni moins nous
sommes forts ajoute ludmilla et personne
ne nous a rendu si fort et si unie que
vladimir poutine lui même personne nick
tour
pour soigner son toit ville
cette maison c'est pour eux le fruit de
quarante ans ne dure labeur
regardez les impacts de balles a dit
elle c'est comme ça que tout a commencé
comme beaucoup dans la région de karkhiv
oleksandr et ludmilla sont d'origine
russe et il ne supporte pas d'avoir
servi de prétexte pour cette invasion
match - trop ce qui est mieux c'est
comme ça les supposés soldats de la paix
russes sont apparemment venus nous
libérer dit elle nous les russophones
mais de quoi exactement
[Musique]
en sortant le couple prend des nouvelles
des voisins ceux qui sont restés sur
place comme vassili origin 87 ans il n'a
pas bougé de chez lui pendant toute
occupation pas question pour lui de
partir malgré le danger malgré cette
roquette tomber dans son jardin à calvi
la pomme but mieux
ils ont bombardé c'est tombé là dit il
moi je n'ai rien demandé le vieil homme
se ces miraculés et en attendant la
visite des démineurs il a juré de rester
ils se sont d'ailleurs bien plus en
sécurité depuis que les soldats russes
ont quitté les villes et les villages
situés au nord et à l'est de karkhiv est
la raison pour laquelle la situation est
un peu plus sécuritaire ici ce que les
forces ukrainiennes sont en train de
mener depuis plusieurs semaines une
vaste contre-offensive contre les
soldats russes on voit d'ailleurs ici la
préparation d'une de ses opérations ce
qui a eu pour effet de repousser les
russes parfois même jusqu'à la frontière
avec leur pays donc de desserrer l'étau
autour de la ville de kharkiv qui
presque maintenant entièrement hors de
portée de l'artillerie russe
cette unité spéciale de l'armée
ukrainienne s'appelle to man brouillard
et ses hommes cachent difficilement leur
fierté car le terrain conquis au prix de
très grands sacrifices est d'une
importance stratégique capitale le
commandant l'unité se fait appeler crâne
il reconnaît que les soldats russes sont
plus nombreux et mieux équipés mais il
affirme que ces sommes sont plus mobiles
et qu'ils connaissent bien le terrain
[Musique]
notre principale force et notre morale
et notre détermination sans faille dit
il
c'est notre terre nous protégeons notre
mère patrie nos enfants notre avenir
dit-il il n'y a pas de meilleure
motivation
on reste son bras droit nous amène au
grand coeur pour nous montrer les armes
récupérées des combattants russes en
déroute
ce sont notre fédé t-il des cadeaux de
la russie comme ceux dragunov un fusil
de sniper
il nous montre aussi un autre cadeau
beaucoup plus utile
1n là une arme antichar britannique qui
a permis de détruire quantité de blindés
russes il en profite pour lancer un
appel aux pays occidentaux tornado
pommerat zapata il est évident que nous
avons besoin de soutien dit il nous
sommes sont motivés mais nous manquons
d'équipements spécialisés des lunettes
de visée nocturne par exemple cette aide
selon eux est le seul moyen de terminer
rapidement cette guerre est donc de
limiter les pertes en vies humaines
une guerre dont alexander et lioudmila
attendre la fin avec impatience ou de
mastrad on peut déjà voir
se promettant mutuellement de tout
reconstruire